20 teal winners all underage 20 $100,000
to drop out of school and pursue our
dreams this is team Technorati raising
money is hard you really have to have
something good it's very unlikely you're
gonna trick an angel or VC into giving
you money there's what's called the seed
round and then beyond that a Series A
Series B 75% of those people I pitched
in the second race still said no once
you are certain of your insurance you
don't really understand that details of
your plan I'm gonna find like tons of
taxes based on exactly where you are
you know the S&P 500 has gone up and
down a bunch I highly recommend no one
actually gonna invest in the stock
market unless you know exactly what
you're doing how many of you feel like
you're in adults already I feel like I
don't have to rely my parents fraud of
you know support in what ways do you not
feel like an adult do you ever not feel
like an adult oh I like that fun I think
it's very difficult to break us into the
non adult in adult portions because we
spend a lot of time in an adult world
we're pitching companies were designing
new technologies you're such a mishmash
of adult and non adult it's pretty
difficult to work out and by the end of
18 what are you really I think that
you're used to the best time in your
life to just take
in Silicon Valley itself like the
mentality is to take risks and jump and
do things that might fail but fail fast
move on
I decided to go into educational
technology to try to make education fun
for everybody because I really hated the
traditional ways we were asked to study
in school some challenges that lie ahead
for the company in trying to form is
it's a very very tough market to break
through and I don't think anyone has
broken through the consumer side of it
know I can cut the shirt up it's too
small no it's game day today yeah I'm
currently internet Facebook and I've
been balancing that with the Keough
fellowship I just get to have no I was
in a sorority I definitely miss my
sorority since there's so much I've been
facebooking and texting them constantly
since I've came here
my dream is to be able to make an impact
in someone's life I've been talking to a
few incubator programs and I'll be
meeting with them to see if I can get
some extra funding tune in for the next
episode of team technorati when Google
challenges us to prove ourself and be
sure to subscribe to the wired Channel